KUNAL SONI: Hi, everyone.
Thanks, Francis.
I'm Kunal.
And I look after the Google
Play Apps and Games business
for Southeast Asia and India.
Welcome.
It's fantastic to have all
of you here, this evening,
and to be talking to you
about the exciting world
of mobile apps.
So clearly, I think, as Google,
one of our most important
objectives is to work with
you all, our developers,
our partners, to help create
high quality apps, apps that
will connect meaningfully
with users in India
and touch lives, delight users,
engage users, and entertain
users.
Right?
As we all know, Android has
seen some massive momentum
over the last few years.
And the exciting
part is that even
going forward, given that
there is so much opportunity
for smartphone penetration
in this country to improve,
that momentum will continue
to drive growth forward.
Right?
As a community, I think
the one big challenge
that we need to think
deeply about-- if we
are to really unlock
this opportunity
and make on-boarding, engaging,
and retaining users easier--
is about creating apps
that will work effectively
in the hardware and
connectivity landscape
that you see in India today.
Will this app work even
if connectivity is poor?
Will this app work effectively
across various devices?
Those are very, very
important questions.
So in other words, as
the title suggests,
how do we create apps
that are fit for India?
That's going to be the focus
of this discussion today.
Let's move forward.
And let's quickly look
at the opportunity
that we see on Android.
Super exciting.
Canalys, which is a
leading research firm,
predicts that in just
over two years from now,
India will have about half
a billion smartphone users.
And as you can see, from
the green bar right there,
Android will be at the
forefront of that revolution.
Right.
So clearly, the challenge
does not lie in users
or getting enough
users for content.
The challenge could
be in making sure
that the content that
you create is engaging
enough and impactful enough.
There are three
challenges that we
need to think deeply about,
as we think about delivering
an excellent user experience.
Let's talk about the first one.
The first one is related to
mobile connections because
of connectivity in this country.
Unfortunately, the average
connection speed, or even
the peak average
connection speed,
tends to be among the lowest,
in this country, globally.
And that's something which
impacts user experience
and, therefore, should be
an input into your own app
development lifecycle.
Let's talk about the
second challenge.
And that relates to the
quality and adoption
of broadband in India.
Interesting stat-- just 11%.
Just 11% of all of the
broadband connections
in the country, today, operate
at speeds greater than 4 Mbps.
And even a smaller
percentage operate
at speeds greater than 10 Mbps.
So clearly, I think
all of these factors
influence the kind
of user experience
and the kind of data
consumption that you
can drive through your apps.
Let's talk about
the third challenge
that we need to take
into account, which
is about affordability of data.
The relative cost of
data, as measured by cost
as a percentage of per capita
national income, in India,
is high compared to some
other markets in the region.
Even a market like
Singapore, for example,
is eight times cheaper when
you look at relative data
cost for mobile data--
for mobile broadband--
and 12 times cheaper when
it comes to mobile data.
So clearly, there is work
to be done, to make data
more affordable, and
at the same time, work
to be done in creating
content that works effectively
despite all these challenges.
So what do you want to do?
Our vision is really to help you
work through these challenges
and create apps that
will work effectively
despite these conditions.
Apps that will
empower the next wave
of online users in the country.
Apps that will build trust
and confidence among users.
And clearly, apps that will
deliver a seamless, consistent
experience,
regardless of devices,
regardless of connectivity.
That's what our goal is.
So how do you do this?
It's a nice, noble
thought to have.
How do you do this?
What we've done is, essentially,
worked with a lot of experts,
both within Google
as well as outside,
to come up with a list of
practices and guidelines
that we believe are
important for you
to take into account as
you think about getting fit
for India.
So essentially,
what we've done is
we've identified a set of
benchmarks and best practices
across connectivity,
compatibility, and cost,
and essentially identified
certain tools and procedures
that you should be taking
into account, into your app
development cycle.
To tell you more
about this, I'm going
to invite Ankur Kotwal from
the developer advocate team
at Google, to take you
through this, in more detail.
Please welcome Ankur.